[Music]
if you have an Android phone you
probably love downloading new apps on
the Google Play Store but did you know
that what you were really looking for
does exist as long as you look at the
right place stay tuned until the end to
see which app made us scared of Android
users if you love technology as much as
we do make sure you visit our friends at
the hub today we're showing you ten
secret apps not on the Google Play Store
popcorntime
first we have to warn you that the
reason why most of these apps don't make
it to the Google Play Store is that
they're breaking the rules the law might
not be the same in every state in every
country but you still have to know that
you're not supposed to use most of these
apps some of them can even be a little
dangerous and this is why they're secret
if it just made you more curious and
you're not afraid to get in trouble you
have to keep watching first we'll start
with a rule that most people already
love to break watching movies for free
online with popcorn time you can watch
almost any movie and TV show as much as
you want as long as you have an internet
connection they're constantly searching
for the best torrents online from the
best sites they will find the best
version possible with HD and subtitles
so you can start streaming it right away
they can't guarantee that all the links
will work but this is why there are so
many so you'll always find a way to
watch your favorite movie and the best
thing about it is that it's completely
free you can find something similar on
the Google Play Store but the best thing
about the app that you download online
is that they promise that the service
will never be taken down hey guys we are
so excited to announce we are producing
our own original content head over to
the trendy for the best DIYs fashion
tips makeup hacks and so much more we
are sure you're going to love it and be
sure to let us
affection you left me here from you see
you there
ad away if you don't have to pay for a
nap you know that most of the time it's
only because you're going to see a ton
of ads we're so used to it that we don't
see it anymore but sometimes we have to
stop playing to watch a video or even
accidentally click on something that was
in the way it made Android users so
upset that someone had to create an app
to get rid of the ads it might not be
fair for the creator's who only make
money with the ads but we have to admit
that we wouldn't have to do that if the
ads were more user friendly with AD away
you can block the ads for most of the
apps and websites on your phone it's an
open source and free software that lets
you select your own sources of hosts
files unfortunately it doesn't work with
every app and can even make them stop
working this is why you can add the
exceptions to the whitelist and a Dawei
will be blocked on these apps you'll
still have ads on these applications but
at least they'll keep working a Dawei
can be a little complicated to use but
you can also go to their website to find
the answers to all of your questions
once you know how it works you see that
it's totally worth it to mate if you
love downloading free songs you probably
used LimeWire a couple years ago now
that it doesn't exist anymore
you've probably turned to YouTube to
find your favorite songs all you need is
a youtube converter and you can turn the
videos into an mp3 file and listen to
the songs on your phone we're not saying
that this is the right thing to do but
we all have to admit that this is what
most people do however you need a
computer to do this and this is what
makes things more complicated but you'll
be happy to hear that you can now do
this on your Android phone too with
TubeMate its job is simply to let you
download videos from YouTube directly
onto your mobile phone it's really easy
to use just search for the video that
you like in the browser and press the
green arrow at the bottom of the screen
you can even choose the quality that you
want to download your video in with
different resolution options adapted to
different terminals this is how you can
have access to all your favorite songs
and videos on your SD card memory and
watch them whenever you want if you love
our videos you can even download them to
listen to them in your car just don't
forget to subscribe and tell your
friends about our channel if you do this
ex Tunes we love listening to free music
on our phone and this is why we're
always trying to find new ways to listen
to music if you want to find an easier
way to download your favorite songs on
your Android phone ex Tunes is the app
that you need and the reason why it's a
secret is that you will get all these
songs
for free don't tell the authorities that
you're doing this but if you really want
to break the rules that's your choice
what we love about this app is that you
can have access to trending music on the
Billboard charts and the monthly hit
songs you have Beyonce Lady Gaga The
Weeknd and so much more but you can also
discover a lot of music that you never
heard before from artists all around the
world you can also simply use the
browser if you're looking for all the
songs from your favorite artists once
you find what you were looking for all
you have to do is click on mp3 download
it's just like iTunes but for someone
who is on a budget and this is obviously
where the name comes from X Tunes is the
best alternative to listen to free music
all day no matter where you are make
sure you download this as soon as the
video ends PokerStars we should warn you
that this app is not for anyone under 18
years old and no that's not because
you're going to see some pretty girls
that's because you might end up losing a
lot of money or be part of the lucky
ones that are going to earn some you'll
be playing poker with real money if you
think that you have what it takes to win
here's your chance but if you think that
wasting your time is already enough and
you don't want to waste your money you
should probably stick to games that you
can play just for fun if you go on the
google play store you will find a lot of
apps that will let you play poker but
they won't let you play for money and
that's why you'll have to turn in to a
secret app PokerStars this app is like
any poker game that you can find online
but this time you also have access to a
mobile cashier to manage your bankroll
on the move from your mobile device make
real money deposits to use on PokerStars
and start playing in the hope of earning
real money we have to warn you that only
a few people win but if you're over 18
years old it is your choice whether you
want to take a chance or not live net TV
we've already told you about some apps
that are going to give you the chance to
watch your favorite movies for free but
sometimes we don't have that much time
and we just want to watch television the
new generation doesn't have TV screens
at home anymore because they watch
everything online and now you can watch
whatever you want whenever you want and
wherever you want on your mobile phone
can television get any better yes and
it's by making all those TV shows free
to watch as long as you can pay for a
good internet connection or even just
fine free Wi-Fi you can binge watch
television all day for free with the
live net TV you can have access to all
your favorite channels and you won't
have to wait a whole week to watch the
next episode there are tons of seasons
just waiting for you to watch them new
episodes are
also updated daily as soon as possible
the simple design makes it easy to use
and there are no sign ups or
subscriptions everything is free this
app just looks perfect but we have to
tell you that this is actually against
the law in some countries so don't do
this if you don't like breaking the
rules but we're still here to tell you
that apps like this do exist Amazon
Appstore if you go on Google Play you
can find amazon shopping Amazon Prime
video Amazon Kindle and Prime photos
from Amazon
but there is one app that Google doesn't
want you to see that's because if more
people knew about it it could be their
biggest competition Amazon can offer you
a whole new app store on your Android
phone and it's simply called the Amazon
App Store you probably already know what
it does but you're wondering why you
should download this - with Amazon
Appstore you can discover top apps and
games and get recommendations based on
the titles that you love it's just like
the Apple App Store and actually it's so
similar that Apple tried to sue Amazon
because of the name of the app you might
think that you already have all of this
on Google Play but what we love about
the Amazon App Store is that some of
these games are actually cheaper it's so
cheap that many creators were upset that
they're not making as much money as they
would like with the Amazon App Store but
they did that to make you happier so
some of you might like to take advantage
of the situation you can even save money
on apps and in-app items with Amazon
coins we don't know about you but we
think that we should absolutely give it
a try f-droid here's another kind of app
store for those who like everything to
be free as long as we're not wasting any
money why would be complained the
f-droid is an installable catalog of
Foss free and open source software apps
for Android there are only thousands of
apps on this store compared to the more
than 1 million on the Google Play Store
but we think that it still deserves a
try do you want to know why you don't
need to register for an account to
browse and download the apps from
f-droid you'll also have access to
important information about the app that
the Google Play Store usually doesn't
want you to know features like
advertising user tracking or dependents
are flagged in the description so you'll
know about this before using them what
we love about this is that the app was
created by volunteers users and
developers are the ones who submit new
apps the only requirement is that the
app needs to be free of proprietary
software this is also why it might take
you more time to find what you're
looking for but we think that it's
totally worth it at the end if you want
to help the volunteers working on the
app you can always donate now that's an
application that you can proudly
download
humblebundle we all love playing games
on our phones when we have nothing to do
but most of us don't like to pay for
them why would we pay ninety nine cents
when we can have plenty of other games
for free it sounds totally dumb when we
think about it but it makes sense in our
head
however this application might make you
change your mind the reason why it's not
on the Google Play Store is not that
it's breaking the rules but because it's
their biggest competitor and we're
pretty sure that once you hear about
this app you'll want to spend a lot of
money even though you never did it on
Google Play wanna hear why Humble Bundle
gives you the opportunity to buy apps
for the best price that you can ever
find everything comes in a bundle so you
won't only get the chance to download
your favorite games but also discover
new ones you can find games for more
than $10 games for more than five
dollars and even just choose to pay what
you want if you just love Humble Bundle
you can even pay for a subscription it's
12 dollars a month and you get over $100
in games what we love about Humble
Bundle is also that the money goes to
the right people
and it can even go to charity how did we
live for so many years without this app
network spoofer we hope that none of our
friends are ever going to use this app
because it can be really scary
we're not here to encourage you to do
this but to tell you that applications
like this do exist are you ready to hear
about this network spoofer lets you hack
other people's computer with your
Android phone all you have to do is find
a Wi-Fi network login choose a spoof to
use and press start for example you can
change the text on a page you simply
have to select a word or a letter and
replace it with something else you can
also change all the pictures they see
online into one funny picture that you
selected don't worry you can't really do
anything mean or dangerous with this app
it's meant to show how vulnerable home
networks can be too simple attacks just
make sure that you always get permission
before doing that and just try it on a
friend that has a good sense of humor
never use network spoofer on a
non-residential network like a school or
a university anyway we don't want to get
in trouble so we'll let you tell us what
happened with this app are you going to
download any secret apps on this list
make sure you tell us which one is your
favorite in the comments down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for 10 secret apps not on the Google
Play Store for more videos like this
make sure you watch 10 most insane
arcade games you won't believe exist
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]